We're back with Stephen King.
Someone I have known my whole life
and love so dearly as we all do
because you've changed the course of all of our lives.
You have painted in the minds of all of us
the greatest stories, scenarios, characters, worlds,
and I'd love to talk to you about some of,
all of our favorites in something we're calling,
On The Books.
Oh, this is gonna be like a Rorschach Test.
Okay, Carrie, published in 1974, movie released in 1976.
What are your thoughts?
Well, what I remember is
that when the movie rights were sold for $6,500,
I ran out to McDonald's and bought my wife
and I Orange Blizzard shakes.
Okay, that is beyond my expectations
or dreams for what this is, that's exactly it!
Okay, The Shining, published in 1977,
movie released in 1980.
Well, I didn't really like the movie that much
but I did like the little boy that played Danny Torrance.
And of course, since then,
"Here's Johnny" has become associated with my name forever.
And why did you not love the movie?
Not to press, if you don't wanna tell me it's fine,
but I'm curious.
No, the book was warm and the movie was cold.
It was a Kubrick film and don't get me wrong,
I love everything else the man did.
I just didn't like that one.
The greatest thing about it is if you're not involved,
if it's really good, you can say that's based on my book.
If it's really bad, you can say,
I didn't have anything to do with it.
(Drew laughing loudly)
Okay, Firestarter, published in 1980,
movie released in 1984, shot in '82.
I thought that you were terrific in that part.
That was very, very difficult, and you were great.
Every time that you got ready to light a fire
your beautiful blonde hair would blow back.
It was great.
That's it!
Yup, that's the look
I loved getting to play Charlie McGee
more than words can ever express.
And when you're seven and you think you can blow people away
with a fireball, it's really empowering.
(audience laughing)
Yeah.
Okay, so from Different Seasons in 1982 came,
Stand By Me, the movie in 1986.
What I remember about writing that was my wife
and I were living in an old house
that was too small for a writing room.
And so there was a barn next door
and I used to work on Stand By Me,
which was then called, The Body,
in my underwear because it was summer
and it was so hot in there
but the memories just came flooding back.
Oh, I love that detail.
That's right, The Body, of course.
(Drew gasping)
I love that.
Okay, one of my personal favorites,
they're all my favorites.
Christine, published in 1983, movie released in 1983.
That's a quick turnover.
I had a Plymouth like that.
It wasn't quite that year
but it was rattly and it was breaking down.
And one day when I was driving it home
I thought to myself, you know,
what would be really great is if the odometer
on this thing started to run backwards
and every time it turned past, like a fender bender
or a flat tire, that thing would fix itself.
And I thought, you know, that's a great story.
I think I wanna write that, it'll be really funny,
but it didn't turn out to be that funny after all.
I love that, it's brilliant.
Okay.
Another book you wrote that also
became such an incredible movie, Misery.
Published in 1987, movie in 1990.
At that time, you know, I went to autograph things
and people would line up
and they would all say the same thing,
I'm your number one fan.
(Drew laughing)
I thought to myself, you can't all be my number one fan.
Somewhere there must be a number two fan
or a number three, but they would bring things.
And some of them were very, very serious about
various parts of the stories and everything,
and I thought, you know,
I would hate to be captured by one of these
and have to write a book.
And then the thing just followed after.
I mean, it was just perfect.
It was like automatic writing almost.
And a detail about your new novel, Later.
I had an idea for a story about
a literary agent, a woman, who was on her own
and she had financial problems
and she had one big client that was supposed
to pay all the bills because her life was just falling apart
and the guy drops dead.
So what are you gonna do about that?
And I held onto that idea for quite a while.
And then I thought, what if she had a kid who could talk
to dead people and they had to tell him the truth.
And I thought that little boy could tell her the whole story
and she could write it under his name.
So I started with that and I just,
I had such a good time with that book.
And I hope people who read it have a good time.
It's sort of light and tasty,
but I think it's also scary, so.
I just love being in your world for years
and I'm so happy to reconnect with you.
Well, right back at you, I love being with you
and getting a chance to connect with you
and see your happy face.
And I just hope everything's going great for you.
And I watch the show and I read your book
and you were in Firestarter and you were in Cat's Eye.
Now, we have a real connection, it's great.
We really do.
Just don't lock me up in a room and make me write a book.
Well, I am your number one fan.
(Stephen shrieking)
(Drew laughing loudly)
Oh, I love you, Stephen King.
Thank you so much for coming here.
Please, if you'll come on your next project
I would be so honored.
Later, is available now!
It dropped, it's here and we will be-
It's here.
(upbeat music)